did you know that bellatrix lestrange
actually wore a tight corset with all
that black
no wonder she was always in such a bad
mood we've got
real behind-the-scenes magic to thank
for the amazing costumes worn by our
favorite witches and wizards
janie tameim and her team designed
everything from those memorable uh-ball
outfits to the hogwarts house uniforms
we all love
and probably wore for halloween once or
twice some of the tricks they used
helped make hagrid seem
seven feet tall and inspired realistic
quidditch uniforms that you could
actually play sports in here are all the
best behind-the-scenes wardrobe secrets
straight from hogwarts of course you'll
know all about hogwarts
hermione walking down those stairs in a
dress that was seemingly made of pink
starlight took
our breath away the first time and it's
still taking our breath away today
this now famous pink and purple chiffon
dress was chosen because it has a
magical quality
and while it's elegant and sophisticated
it also looks like something a 16 year
old girl would wear
it was important to get the dress just
right because it's at that moment that
ron and harry see hermione
in a whole different light the costume
department didn't want them to see her
as something she's not
so the dress was meant to help show them
the different layers of hermione
just like all the different layers in
the gorgeous gown
she looks beautiful yeah she does
ron really does look like a disaster at
times disheveled clothing
and we can't ever forget his yule ball
outfit but a lot of effort went into ron
looking like he puts
zero effort into his wardrobe in fact
rupert grint was more into fashion when
he was young than either of his co-stars
he took great joy in making sure ron's
outfits were always perfectly imperfect
he got so into character that he even
showed up to the order of the phoenix
premiere
in true wrong fashion wearing slacks and
a harry potter t-shirt
you ever stop eating
i'm hungry bellatrix may not look like
someone you'd want at your dinner party
but under all that black
she's dressed to impress since helena
bonham carter had starred in her fair
share of period pieces
she had no problem with the costume
department fitting her with a tight
corset and long
locks to add extra drama to her look the
corset also adds some medieval elements
and as much elegance as bellatrix can
muster she's from a super old
traditional wizarding family after all
so the constricting wardrobe makes
perfect sense
pretty baby
ivana lynch had the time of her life
playing luna lovegood
so much so that she used to sleep with
luna's long blonde extensions still in
her hair so she could feel like she was
still in character
we can understand that since laning the
role was such a huge accomplishment for
her
ivana has put so much of herself into
the character that she used to help
select luna's jewelry
and she even had a hand in making that
gryffindor lionhead
together her and the costume department
created looks that quirky potter fans
are still recreating it's a charm
actually
keeps away the nargles ginny weasley
might not have been so fashion forward
if it wasn't for bonnie wright who loved
taking a hands-on approach to styling
her character
in fact bonnie was actually the cast
member most obsessed with fashion
and had more say in her costume than
emma watson did for hermione's wardrobe
bonnie's inspiration comes from her
parents who are well-known jewelers
she'd love to get in on the clothing and
accessories her character would be
wearing
so a lot of the outfits you see her in
are directly inspired by bonnie herself
it seems silly doesn't it a wedding
given everything that's going on
philip tracy designed hats for the film
and he had the best time creating the
elegant french-inspired hats worn by the
all-girls school
the slight angle reflects the french
aspect while the color of the wardrobe
is soft
feminine and chic but also has hard
angles to show that
these witches aren't to be messed with
by the time prisoner of azkaban came
around
the golden trio had already taken on
their fair share of trolls
spiders and giant snakes the wardrobe
department really wanted to remind the
audience that these were just
kids and they weren't always prepared to
jump headfirst into danger
you probably noticed a lot of casual
clothing like hoodies and sweaters and
this was entirely on purpose
to make them look like they were really
just young teenagers trying to figure
themselves out and it also made a little
more sense than other movies where the
trio spent most of their time at
hogwarts dressed in their uniforms
that felt good not good brilliant
fred and george do pretty much
everything together apparently
they also coordinate their outfits the
costume department would put the twins
in different outfits that always
complemented each other
for example if one was wearing stripes
the other might wear something with dots
or squares in the same color
james and oliver phelps would even help
pick out costumes and style their
twinning looks
the coordinated outfits added a visual
style of comedy to the two brothers
and it also showed that the two of them
enjoyed poking fun at themselves for
being twins
five galleons i'm your brother 10
gallons
dumbledore's closet might be filled with
elegant and magical robes but they would
have been completely different if the
costume department had known he was gay
when the movies first started filming jk
rowling hadn't yet shared this piece of
info
but if she had his wardrobe throughout
the movies would have helped reflect
that
janie to mime didn't go into details
about the changes she would have made
but we'd love to see her interpretation
of dumbledore now that she knows the
whole story
well being me has its privileges
fans have always been a little upset
that movie harry didn't share his
mother's green eyes but it turns out
that they did try to get the eye color
right
it just wasn't worth the discomfort it
caused daniel radcliffe he was only 11
when he first starred in sorcerer's
stone and has naturally blue eyes
when they tried contacts he described
them as being excruciatingly painful
if we had to choose between daniel
radcliffe and green eyes
we'd choose daniel every time
better be gryffindor
robbie cole train who played hagrid
isn't a giant in real life
not that you would know that given how
great of a job they did convincing us
that he was humongous
a lot of work went into this movie magic
including his wardrobe he was outfitted
with huge robes in lots of layers to
make him look more full-bodied and as
for the height
there was actually a body double martin
mayfield is six feet ten inches tall
and he added to his height by wearing a
realistic and
creepy hagrid mask over his face the
rest of the magic was done with clever
camera angles
and lots of miniature furniture rubius
hagrid
keeper of keys and grounds at hogwarts
harry potter glasses are a major fashion
trend and a lot of people wear them
without lenses just so they can pull off
the look
daniel radcliffe said that almost every
pair of glasses used in the film
was lensless to avoid awkward
reflections while filming
and also to avoid using oculus repairo
every time he had an
action-packed fight scene after the
series wrapped harry actually got to
take two pairs of these lensless glasses
home with him
the tiny pair from the first movie and
the very last pair he ever wore
in the eighth when it comes to a
wizard's favorite sport
bright colors rugby and american
football were all sources of inspiration
the problem was that the quidditch
outfits couldn't be too heavy because
the actors would be flying on
animatronic brooms
which was already uncomfortable enough
the wardrobe team worked for months to
get them right
and ended up going with nylon to make
sure they were as comfortable as they
were sporty
another fun piece of quidditch trivia
harry potter's jersey number in the
movies was seven
and it was inspired by david beckham
gryffindor we all noticed that the tone
of the harry potter films started to
change with prisoner of azkaban they
were becoming more and more serious
and the kids were growing up so the
costume department decided to do an
entire rework of the hogwarts uniform
in the first two movies the robes were
mostly black and the students kind of
blended together
they were also a lot more juvenile but
once azkaban came around
they decided to highlight the house
colors by sewing thick lining
into the robes they also added hoods
collars and silk ties in the house
colors
i think we'll never just have a quiet
year hogwarts
daniel radcliffe wasn't the only one who
got away with a piece of his wardrobe
hermione actually kept one of her wands
the time turner and a cloak
perfect for a harry potter halloween
costume rupert grint on the other hand
took things to a whole other level by
taking the golden egg from the triwizard
tournament but they tracked him down
and took it back however he did get away
with
stealing the four off the dursley's
house and the crew gave him dumbledore's
deluminator as a gift
so at least he didn't have to steal that
one pretty much
what is it which harry potter
character's wardrobe is your favorite
have you ever tried recreating any of
your favorite wizarding outfits yourself
let us know in the comments down below
don't forget to hit that like button and
subscribe to the things for more great
stuff
thanks for watching and see you next
time